[Musique]
courir en liberté
longez la baie de saint-paul et
rejoindre la savane et les hautes herbes
de la pointe de la marianne c'est un
parcours en play d'histoire que vont
emprunter ces 400 coureurs pour la
première édition du trail de vilaine
[Musique]
à
la confiance est déjà dépassée de vendée
lieu mémoriel bien entendu on passera
devant le cimetière marin de la grotte
des premiers français on aura le moulin
cader donc c'est vraiment des lieux mais
quand même
important pour notre histoire donc
je pense les à l'aide notamment vont
apprécier ce à quoi ses premiers indices
[Musique]
non
allemand
[Musique]
en
et une arrivée symbolique dans la cour
de l'habitation de la famille des
bassins au musée de villèle un temps
fort pour les commémorations du 170e
anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé une belle réussite avec une
belle ambiance je vois des coureurs bien
sûr frappe figueruelas coassements mais
heureux heureux d'avoir participé
heureux d'être avec nous ici à ces
moments de commémoration de l'abolition
de l'esclavagé le goût de l'effort le
sport élèves les valeurs humaines
alors bravo à tous les participants
[Musique]
super organisation cordes et mentale des
bénévoles génial vraiment
athènes et bruxelles vous reviendrez
mais voilà bravo
[Musique]